oh miss Karen can I stop for a minute my
back is hurting keep going I didn't hear
anything
snap this year I'm making your figgy
pudding with rat poison and
Ajax but no
[Music]
raisins
beautiful now you do
me hey francer hey
Vixen hey
Blitz
oh good good just in time can I put the
star on I want to put the star in can I
put the star on cuz I got a really good
one this
year now the other ornaments have
something to Aspire
to yes look at it there shining like a
beacon of
unemployment so Wilman now that you've
gotten rid of the old ball and chain got
any Christmas Eve plans oh yeah I'm
going to spend the whole evening by my
myself yeah I'm going to string
cranberries around the tree get my
jammies and watch every version of A
Christmas Carol ever made M and which
one do you think you'll be watching when
you kick the chair out from under
you hey there's a difference between
being alone and being lonely I am
lonely honey why don't you join Jackie
and me and my suite at The Palace Hotel
huh it's going to be a real oldfashioned
Christmas the stock will be hung by the
chimney with care and I'll be stinking
drunk and then at midnight we're going
to crawl in the bed and wait for the
sound of Whooves on the roof no honey
Rosie's not
invited so what do you say and pass up
my annual screening of eie starring
Susan Luchi as the definitive female
Scrooge yeah I'll be there at
6 hey maybe we should invite Grace and
Leo oh I already invited them what
before me no come on crazy after I
invited
you J gosh hey
hey Merry
Christmas graceon
Leon hey police na dude
hey we just came by to try some of your
famous Christmas cookies Grace has been
talking about them all week oh I don't
bake those till tomorrow see you
wait uh well
we brought you something for your tree
well I thought you were against the
whole tree thing you know cuz you're
Jewish well it's your place now I'm not
going to impose my beliefs on you oh a
star of
David what who is this David he's
completely stolen my
idea we got it as a wedding gift next
Christmas you're getting a Seder
plate um Karen you know I I know we told
you a couple of weeks ago that we were
going to go to your thing at the palace
but a couple of weeks ago after
you but we we're not going to be able to
make it cuz uh we got tickets to The
Nutcracker I am so jealous how did you
get tickets for Christmas Eve I've been
calling every day since
June that information does not leave
this room you know it's kind of ironic
actually I I treated a guy who took a
puck to the groin during a pickup hockey
game and he gave me two tickets to The
Nutcracker yeah it' be even more ironic
if the ballet were called crap now I
can't have
kids hey you're not Santa Claus close
though you got a couple of white hair
sprouting on your chin you look like you
just came down the
chimney we'd make a good team your nose
is so red you could guide my slay
tonight and that was Glenn number 11
after him I went home took a nap went to
the gym which is where I I met
Maron number
12 the
Ang Jackie I love the story of the 12
gays of
Christmas miss Ken we have a little
visitor oh for God's sake I'm not your
mother you know where the tampons
are it's your stepdaughter Olivia you
Ghost of Christmas passed
out a Rosie I love it when your slams
turn
seasonal means that Christmas is just
around the
corner what the hell is Olivia doing
here anyway well her ugly mother and fat
brother are in the
hospital they're sucking out part of his
stomach and putting it into her flat
Fanny ah the circle of life
anyway Olivia needs a place to stay for
Christmas yeah well you can tell her to
forget it I'm not running a freaking YMC
hey look at
you hi Karen hi Jack I hope it's okay
that I'm staying it won't be that long I
would have stayed with my stepfather but
he's going to be busy operating on my
mom and
brother honey you can stay for as long
as you want a curly seems like just
yesterday I was holding you in my office
arms and then frantically passing you
off to a
nanny great to see you Rosie
taker why am I so nice now I'm stuck
with
her well there go my Christmas plans of
sitting in a dark room and
drinking and there go my Christmas plans
of turning you so you don't choke on
your own
vomit she's ruining both of our holidays
Jackie
unless unless
what
unless she just ruined yours why don't
you take care of
her no Karen she's a teenage girl
they're very cruel the last time I saw
Olivia I was wearing Uggs which
apparently had gone out of style exactly
5 minutes before I walked
in she gave me such a dressing down I
ended up sobbing and curled up in the
feal position
[Laughter]
honey don't you
mean
a well come on Jackie help me out here
no Karen this is your resp I'll pay you
,000 a minute and I have a
[Music]
daughter you know what I kind of like
eating dinner without Grace there's
enough for seconds and nobody stabs my
hand with the fork when reaching for a
lamb
chop she went to the theater with my
mother I'd have gone but this is my
firm's busiest time of the year I am
swamped organizing the Christmas potluck
it is such hard work you would believe
the number of hours I put in luckily I I
build them mall to a rich drunk client
he'll never know the difference you're a
smart man will that's why you're my
lawyer well I'm just going to come out
and say it Billy Crystal is an American
treasure 700 Sundays is a big fat
hit I could only make it through 200
sunnies before I had hit the
can hi Mom I'm so sorry I couldn't make
it office emergency oh I know I know the
potluck oh well I better run if I'm
going to make my train Grace I had so
much fun with you I felt like I was out
with my new best friend I had a great
time too we're going to have to do this
again sometime well I am giving a lady's
tea tomorrow afternoon at my house catch
the 136 train and I will pick you up on
my way home from the market wow that's
specific and
soon um sure why not I'll see you
tomorrow 306 okay get home safe Wheels
Mom oh that face I'm gelling I learned
that from Billy
Crystal he taught us so many things
tokas plots
well so long my little
fala look at all this food we are so
blessed I know there are poor people who
dream their whole lives of a meal like
this honey I know what we should
do let's take a picture of us eating and
show it to
them wow Karen you are like a female
[Laughter]
Jesus come on Grace why can't we have an
office Christmas party last years was a
disaster you got drunk told me you love
me and then kissed me in the service
elevator I thought that was Valentine's
Day no on Valentine's Day you got drunk
and felt me up in the Swatch room
[Music]
I'm a sucker for the
holidays hey
CH I can't play with you guys right now
my boss Darlene is tipsy with
crazy Jesus here she comes hi Darlene
you look pretty you look forness you
look beautiful that dress is a total
booby trap you can't borrow it um are
they anybody or are they just customers
oh these are customers this is Karen
she's a rich pricey item type and this
is Grace she's a one good basic and lots
of crap
type hi I just forgot your names and
faces oh honey you just gave me a great
idea what to get Rosario for Christmas a
new
face I'm going to call plastic surgeon
see if he can give her cat
ey maybe she won't look so weird
scratching to get in
isn't she great
no nothing's great my window designer
Simon threw a fit and took off to
bise a gays they're just as bad as
women wait a minute you need a designer
to do a Barney's Christmas window that's
that's like a dream job let me handle
this before you screw it
up Dorene you may not know it but at
this very moment you are standing in
front of one of of the best designers on
the planet oh well maybe top five who is
it well isn't it
obvious me
what oh what the hell I'm desperate and
it's one of the smaller windows in the
part of the sidewalk this smells like
urine and pretzels you're hired thank
you thank you thank you so much don't if
this one isn't Grill I will go carnival
freak crazy on your ass I'm serious I
will scratch your eyes out
I can't believe this is happening is
this really happening somebody Pinch
Me be important Jack I was on the roof
chain
smoking okay Darlene you know how you
said you wanted something really edgy
well hold on to your yellow
teeth because here it is the theme to my
Barney's Christmas window
is
somebody's been
naughty jene this is Santa's ho ho
ho what it's fabulous right oh wait and
for reindeer we're going to have eight
little buff men and box briefs on all
fours with antlers can you see it can
you see it dud do your bit do your bit
care okay I've been on Dasher on dancer
on Prancer on Dixon
on comment on Cupid on Donner but not on
Blitz and he likes to watch
[Applause]
okay and that's just the beginning
tomorrow I'm holding a casting session
for the three not so wise but very hot
men okay I'm going to stop talking now
you go you better be kidding me with
this crap this isn't a window for
Barney's New York New York this is a
window for the fairies who are going to
get their eyes scratched out
stor now you have 24 hours to get this
right or not only will I fire you I will
rehire you pull your hair and fire you
again I don't know where you get your
jewelry
but this necklace is
delicious don't start without me Mom
what are you doing I'm getting ready to
enjoy the show what's your game
woman
and Now ladies and gentlemen introducing
Jordy St
James that's a stage name I had to
Nick's Dame Jordy
Dench Santa Claus Mr Santa Claus I get
the kids Applause Mr Santa Claus that
boy is the next Wayne
Newton how many blue marylands have you
had well shush you shush will you
shush will you
shush
this is jordy's moment and keyboard solo
Jordy you're in the audience for the
[Music]
sweetheart
that that
[Music]
CLA bravo bravo okay that that is it
how dare you enjoy your grandson's
Christmas show right in front of me well
William what is your problem I don't
know maybe it's that is that you ruined
every single Christmas play I ever did I
I mean you give him a standing ovation
but for me you'd be fidgeting looking at
your watch melting a a cherry secret
into your stupid secret
[Laughter]
drink un believable we'll just had to
steal the spotlight that's okay Jack I
don't mind he stole it from me Jory grow
up here's your
scotch I wanted a hot cider oh here's
your hot
cider There It Is We're officially in
Connecticut where the whites keep down
the other
whites starting to dread Christmas at
the
trumans every time someone says Merry
Christmas your mother looks at me with
pity and says an
Hanukkah but honey won't it be fun for
you maybe you can bang Will's brother
[Music]
again oh hey honey wow I love your new
bag
it's garbage thank God you said
it okay listen to me I need you to do me
a favor I um I need you to help Jack out
with that window he's in a real pickle
Jack wanted to do the job let him do it
Grace it's Christmas for goodness sake
think about the baby
Jesus up in that Tower letting his hair
down so the three wise men can climb up
and spin the drel and see that there's
six more weeks of
[Laughter]
[Applause]
winter where'd you get that from the
bartenders
Bible forget it all right honey I can't
change your mind I can see that but uh
we're still friends right come on let's
shake on
it what is this Karen keep your
money Jack's on his own wow what are the
holidays coming to and you can't even
bribe a friend to help a friend who
screwed that friend
over Santa it's
Jackie
first of all I I I just want to say I'm
sorry about the time when I was 11 and
told Timmy Woods that you didn't
exist I was just trying to make him cry
so I could hug
him but now I really need your help this
Barney's window is it's a
disaster I guess I deserve it for
screwing my friend
over but I'm really scared I'm going to
lose my
job so Santa if you help me I promise
I'll never ask for anything ever ever
ever again
ever
amen love
Jack PS um I know I just said that thing
about never asking for anything ever
again but
um if you're feeling generous um I would
like some leather
pants um hair extensions
and the ability to
fly you don't have to worry about me
hooking up with Sam all that stuff
between us it's ancient history no
wasn't that nice the holiday horror is
taking a year off hey Will your brother
just got here oh look what he's got with
him a little Christmas
queer just can it with the queer stuff
in front of my mom I don't think she can
handle having another gay kid in the
family I remember one Christmas she was
so excited when I asked for two GI Jo's
cuz she thought I was building an
army she freaked when she realized I was
really building a
home honey this is the palace we don't
have to go out to Carol come
here here's the ice you asked for oh yes
just put it right over here
[Music]
bman good King w
looked out on the Feast of
Ste
theow deep
Andis bright sh
night poor
came winter
[Applause]
f